The Joe Rogan Experience when I have a
fight an event I have to create this
aura that [__] a force field that
pushes you know my way through things
and
like when me and Conor McGregor faced
off
he was moving all over the place and I
stood my ground I stood so still
I Stood Still and I couldn't be you know
wavered or moved
he's moving all over the place
I mean that says that he was free in
that moment to do so obviously
um
but it was me respectfully
calling him out which shows the
the professional in martial arts that I
have been for so many years how do you
call a man out in a sport that you know
he has a family and
um you know you guys want to hurt each
other and they can honor it in a fair
way and uh promote it to be entertaining
I mean everything he does people watch
that [__] so it was great to have him
there it really boosted the moment for
me
um listen if he decided to do that if
somehow or another they gave him the
green light to do that I did I can't
imagine how that could ever happen but
if it did
if that happened in in a bare knuckle
fight that would be [__] bananas that
would be bananas that would be he's a
good kicker too he kicked Cowboy
cerroneous
to my arm yeah he's a very good kicker
he's a very good kicker he he could do
everything but I mean if somehow another
he agreed to fight Bear Knock On Me
Jesus Christ you know how big that would
be
whoo
my Lord Mike
verses he practices it and that yeah he
beat a guy who got me
so it's a great fight man that would be
wild and it would be cool man they say
it's the Pink Panty night now because I
release a video on Instagram me eating
my girlfriend's panties uh
and uh if they did that in bare knuckle
it would get a million pay-per-view buys
at least
I don't know how many sell what was he
saying to you uh
I love the way he talks
no problem eh that's okay
I just
it just it just happened man before that
fight for that camp oh wow it really so
your friend who died it died just from a
sparring match just a sparring incident
yeah man
oh
terrible and he was everyone knew him he
was so tough such a tough guy it's an
unpredictable thing those kind of
injuries are unpredictable thing so you
know yeah stuff man it
it's [__] even more to fight for
though man that's why
you know I guess I have to I used to say
it back in the day some of my I was one
of my call outs in the UFC whose life
you want me to ruin next
[__] yeah dude that's somebody's life
going [__] up man and it's yours me
let's go
and figure it out give me some money
give me some more I need cooler things